[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages time then to see
what is making the headlines with the
political editors of the guardian and
the Sun hypocrura and Harry Cole both
with us from now until just before
midnight welcome to both of you so to
the front pages then let's take a look
shall we starting with the guardian it
leads with the prime minister's speech
tonight in which he heavily criticized
the reaction of the Chinese government
to recent protests there according to
the eye Rishi sunak could soon preempt a
rebellion from within his own party by
lifting the ban on onshore wind farms
the Metro site Sky news's interview with
the Ukrainian first lady Elena zelenska
who has condemned what she alleges is
the systematic use of sexual violence by
Russian soldiers in her country
the financial times reports that the
president of the European Central Bank
Christine Lagarde has insisted it will
not hesitate to continue raising
interest rates even though the pace of
inflation does appear to be slowing
the daily mail again describing secure
stama's plan to impose VAT on private
schools if labor came to power as a
class war
the times reports on the new Online
safety bill which it says will make
social media firms protect young people
or pay the price
the express claims and exclusive with
news that the NHS is paying millions of
pounds to treat people abroad and ease
the pressure on waiting times
the star has divided loyalties in
tomorrow's World Cup match between
England and Wales simply saying come on
well on that same story at the sun Ops
for a perm Do or Die
while the mirror 2 makes the big match
its top story pride and passion there we
go well a reminder that by scanning the
QR code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out all of those
pages while you watch our guests so
let's bring them in then shall we and uh
join Harry and people welcome to both of
you and Pippa why don't you kick off
then with the guardian story
um and this idea that the Golden Era of
relations between China and the UK is
heralded we remember buyer I by Mrs uh
Cameron and Osborne is is over
yes it was very much a reflection of the
sort of language that they'd used
previously when they were in power and
this was a speech tonight at the Guild
Hall by Rishi sunak which has been
billed as his first big foreign policy
speech he's only been in office for
about a month
um and despite the fact that he has done
a couple of trips in that time he's been
to Ukraine he's obviously he's met
leaders at the cop 27 Summit in Egypt
and he was over in Bali at the G20
Summit where he met not just Biden but
was supposed to meet uh XI although that
that meeting was canceled at the last
minute
um he still hasn't really fleshed out
his vision of uh of what Britain's
Global position should be you know very
little of it he was Chancellor for two
years and most of his Focus was on the
economy particularly as a result of cost
of living crisis and and the pandemic so
um tonight was the moment where he
spilled that out and much of the focus
on his speech has been on what he said
about China this era where we had really
quite sort of uh I wouldn't say
necessarily friendly but but certainly
sort of a constructive relations with
China under Osborne and Cameron uh
appear to be over and it's particularly
interesting because Rishi sinach had a
bit of a reputation when he was
Chancellor among some of the Tory Hawks
towards China on his on his own benches
as maybe being a bit softer in stance
towards it than they were because
obviously his priority was sort of
economic the economic aspect and Supply
chains in China obviously plays a major
role in that regard in the um across
across the globe
um and uh so he was very he was very
hard line after that during the Tory
leadership contest talking about China
representing a threat obviously it was
up against Liz truss who herself had
said that in the UK's uh foreign policy
would formally classify China as a as a
threat and then now we have a sort of
another iteration of that position where
he said yes his golden year is over he's
criticized the creeping authority of
shijin paying uh he's sort of defended
his Civil Disobedience to people on the
streets of Beijing and Shanghai and they
sought on the BBC journalist but he's
described China as a system systemic
challenge which mirrors the language and
the the U.S national security strategy
used but stopped short of Coalition
threat which of course he did in the
summer that inevitably will will set the
hose running a bit and cause some more
Jitters amongst uh amongst the hawkish
story about Ventures but clearly his
focus is on the economic ramifications
of the relationship between Britain and
Britain and China yes pick up on that
Harry but also reflect on us you know
this is a man who has as purpose said
has only been in office for for a mere
weeks what we know about his aims and
Ambitions and how he wants to you know
run his foreign policy unit for example
he talked about resetting relations with
Europe as well evolving our wider
post-brexit relations with Europe
including
um engaging with the new European
political Community not talking about
alignment but having a mature respectful
relationship with Europe so there's that
isn't there the EU and all of those
issues there's Russia we know he's been
to the Ukrainian Capital only recently
and obviously the the China stuff we've
already talked about
yeah I think the problem for sunac here
is that actually you don't really go on
on what he said himself about his
foreign policy views and they were you
know I'm old enough to remember when his
campaign team were accusing Liz Transit
being soft on China and in fact Richie
being the the more hawkish and so it was
quite Stark that he hasn't um got as far
as he went in July July 24th but he said
China is the biggest threat facing this
country even bigger than Russia and we
should on day one of my Premiership we
will reflect that now it's day I don't
know about 36 of his Premiership and we
finally come out to talk to it and he's
a million miles from where he was in the
campaign uh he's also a big promised uh
Liz trust promised a big review of
British defense policy and that was
something that Rishi sunak said he would
do uh by the end of the year was
expected because that's going to
actually set things like the defense
budget things like security spending for
the next five years which would all be
haggled about in the run-up to next
March's budget it now he's kicked that
into the long grass that's now not going
to come to the new year he's confirmed
tonight so there's a little bit of a
feeling of actually he's sort of
slightly treading water here he's buying
his time he doesn't want to go too far
one way the other he's completely lashed
himself to the Americans Viewpoint as um
as we said but the Americans at times
can be very hard light on China and
actually Britain yeah it could end up
playing second fiddle and having to go
along with decisions like stripping out
Huawei from our Communications Network
so it's quite a dangerous game to play
to just say well the Americans have said
it so therefore we're gonna say it
because the Americans might use that as
an opportunity to go actually we think
this this and this and this as well and
you end up there going well actually
well we disagree but so it's it's it
strikes me as a slightly rushed speech
that he didn't particularly want to give
he spent the whole weekend briefing the
papers that he was going to be cracking
down on small boats this week having to
fix the economy apparently in the last
couple of weeks and suddenly we've got a
very late drop of this speech on Sunday
night we've got very late final version
of it almost says he was standing up
this evening and you make you wonder
whether it is slightly written by
committee he didn't want to go too far
either one way or the other and it's
slightly sort of beginning to sum up his
Premiership so far is that he's actually
incredibly risk-averse doesn't want to
upset anyone and he Wonder well you know
that's just management that's just
technocratic government well voters want
a little bit more than that yeah or it's
diplomacy isn't it when it comes to
foreign that's the point I think yeah
but let's not forget that you know China
beating up British journalists on their
streets tonight and all he could
basically say was the one to one
throwaway and remark about that they're
clamping down on Hong Kong they're
threatening Taiwan they're burning
people alive in buildings because
they're zero covered policy you know
what does it take what more evidence
yeah but part of the problem is that
Chinese lockdowns are having a major
impact on Supply chains around the world
for the very reason it's quite hard to
buy an item without part or all of it
being made in China so this this trading
partnership is a you know it's a de
facto reality isn't it for the world and
how they deal with human rights look at
the front page we're going to hurry then
yeah I'm meeting up all the time and
people and I agreed last week that we're
going to have a truth so it's all
talking too much
um
that is the problem of 12 Years or 15
years or 20 years the British foreign
policy is that China got us right where
they want him where they want us
something has to break and so far you
know you've got people like IDs saying
this is just a return to project counter
yeah he's been very Stark tonight has he
not uh Ian Duncan Smith uh problem is
China produced cheap Goods when the
world did not want to I suppose and uh
you know we live with that now but
reflect just quickly if we can if we can
pack in some other stories as well you
know the pictures we see on the front
page of the financial times there is a
bravery about these protests because
China has you know very strongly
um organized facial recognition they
don't need to be there to arrest people
they can subsequently do it you know
we've seen with Iran as well protests
and uh now across parts of China The
Bravery of people who do who do not live
in under a democratic state are Pippa
yes very striking picture of them not
sure if you can see but it's a bank of
Chinese police and officials and a
protester holding up an empty a blank
sheet of paper representing censorship
which of course is one of is one of
their concerns that they're not able to
speak out but ultimately these protests
which you know the most the most sort of
Civil Disobedience we've seen on the
streets of cities like Shanghai for
decades
um are about China's zero covered policy
and it basically what ended up happening
is that local areas have been had very
very extreme shutdowns even if there's
just one case of covid and there's some
concern that um you know the vaccine
isn't that they use isn't as effective
as it is in the west
um and that's why we're seeing by
comparison you know look at the World
Cup there's crowds of thousands of
people all created in together not
wearing masks getting on with life as
usual whereas in China
um there's really sort of severe
restrictions still in place um and it's
you know these local lockdowns it's a
zero covered policy continues
um covered areas which represent or was
produced about two-thirds of China's GDP
can you imagine the impact if those
lockdowns continue on Global Supply
chains and and the economy but if they
remove all the restrictions and lift it
suddenly then we go back to space sort
of familiar territory that we've had in
the UK over the past couple of years of
the Chinese health system being
overwhelmed and then potentially
National lockdown being imposed so you
know the government got itself into a
bit of a mess as to how it's How It
deals with it but this is years on from
when the first um the virus first
emerged and you just thought that the
country might have been able to get to
grips with it by now understandably
people are extremely frustrated by these
very Draconian Draconian restrictions
that have been posed on their lives much
more Draconian really than anything
we've seen and coming out of the streets
to protest and it's you know it's really
quite considerably as you mentioned very
brave of them when you consider the sort
of the sort of a response that we've
seen in the past to these sort sorts of
civil civil protests
let's move on to domestic matters shall
we and two stories here the first one is
the Online safety bill which was there
to literally crack down on online harm
everybody cried free speech is a little
bit like Twitter isn't it where they all
these people to monitor output and then
Elon Musk bought it but anyway it's
being brought back isn't it
um Harry and your paper says this is a
victory for free speech
yeah the ongoing saga of the Online
safety bill which is been going about
Family University about it for four or
five years now it was being drafted and
then it was going to lock up you know
Elon musk's and and Mark Zuckerberg's of
the world if they didn't play ball and
then his old actually no we can't do
that but just find them and then they've
tried to go too far the other way and
say actually you know things that you
could say in the pub if you were to then
write them down on Twitter they would be
legal to say in the pub but illegal on
online it it got sort of bogged down in
in sort of as you say some free speech
issues now they have resurrected it um
it was sort of looking like it was going
to go away under Liz truss was she still
not filed in the campaign one of the
vows he's keeping on like lots of the
other vows he's drops
um to to ditch that legal but harmful
um claws which was upsetting a lot of
people there is some good stuff in there
you know basic age verification checks
for social media firms putting the onus
on to the firms with the threats and
sanction of large fines if they don't do
it at the moment you can just you know
go on Instagram or Facebook or one of
the others say you're 13 years old and
that's that the owners will be on the
firms to to check that
um something parents have been calling
for a long time big fines for for not
putting uh for not deleting pornography
Terror content things like that all the
things that you know for so long the
governments across the world actually
and governments around the world we're
looking to see how we do this because
we're one of the sort of pioneers on
this there's lots of other countries
with similar legislation in the pipeline
to see how the big firms react to our
bill before they Implement their own you
know for so long you know government has
been saying two Tech firms sort this out
yourselves or we will have to do it for
you and it looks like finally the
government have realized that you know
they could say it to their blue in the
face without the threat of a big stick
hitting them where they are in their
profits nothing was going to change
um let's hope you know this does
actually do something because there are
thousands of parents millions of parents
out there are concerned lots of parents
out there who are grieving from the lack
of control of what's online and um if it
actually happens uh we can finally go
and write about something else but it's
been a long time to make in this Bill
yes and the suggestion is there'll be a
greater requirement for firms to provide
adults with tools to hide certain
content so you know you get those
algorithms that build up what you see so
people I'm sure you want to talk about
that but do you mind if I move on I know
you've got children who who that would
affect but anyway just just find a quick
throw in the eye too
um wind farms onshore who's for it who's
against it and why has it got the
government in a pickle oh
well Richie's tonight's been scrambling
to find a compromise today on um
alongshore wind there's this back bench
Rebellion yet another bench Rebellion um
growing about it it was obviously a
policy which um uh Boris Johnson
initially wasn't much of a fan of
onshore wind but it's changed his mind
Liz trusted that actually it was
essential to growth so she decided that
that we could have onshore wind and
Rishi sinach says no no we're much more
interested in offshore wind and we
couldn't possibly have onshore wind
unless it has um if if it doesn't have
public consent if one person locally
objects then forget about it and there
is a rebellion led by Simon Clark the
former leveling up secretary and now
about 50 MPS included some white
high-profile ones including Boris
Johnson Liz trust alok Sharma the um the
former cop president uh all backing it
saying that this is ridiculous if we're
going to be looking at energy Security
in the round and we want to make the
most of Renewables then onshore wind has
to be part of that picture the problem
Rishi Cena currently has is if he agrees
to that and sort of you know bends to to
their demand arms then he's going to
have a probably an equally large number
of rebels on the other side that don't
agree with onshore wind
um and he's already facing Rebellion on
this leveling up Bill over over planning
of a housing targets and those people
presumably would be would represent some
of those that would they would not be
very happy with onshore wind so he's
he's once again trying to sort of tread
a really difficult path
um through the different factions in his
party yet another area where the
conservative party is looking at looking
quite divided and you know he's trying
desperately to sort of be the sticking
cluster that holds it together but I
think as time goes on that sticking
cluster is going to fray not just over
onto a window and Renewables but all
sorts of other issues and we're going to
see really despite the fact they're kind
of keeping their Council for the most
part at the moment more and more issues
where conservative MPS decide that they
want to speak out there you go
diplomatic path at home and abroad it
seems like it's his job currently there
we go anyway lots more stuff to come
including a wee story that caught our
eye in the sun discussing the novel way
science his plan to monitor new diseases
when we come back
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
Press preview with me once again paper
Carrera and Harry Cole from the guardian
and the sun respectively welcome back to
both of you Harry look at the papers a
lot of uh looking ahead to Tuesday night
and that crucial game in Qatar the
Staley star with a simple come on with
the uh the captains there quite a moment
certainly
yep um I think some of our features team
our sports teams have been looking for
pubs on the English and Welsh borders
today where I think there used to be one
that the actual border would almost
divide straight down the middle of the
pub but um an incredible moment the
country will stop tomorrow I suspect cry
into a halt certainly for political
journalists like Pippa and I um it's
been nice to let the sports teams and
the uh sports teams of the Showbiz teams
and the features teams take take a bit
of the slack after a mental six months
so as long as England stay in the World
Cup the more uh more paraniable time
people and I will have to uh put our
feet up and do some Christmas shopping
so multiple multiple reasons to cheer
brief respite
um since it's been busy since 2016 I
think probably is how I would describe
it in the world of politics at the Sun
as well do or die that's the same for
the Metro it's Do or Die
um Pippa I know it's not necessarily you
know your team right now and I apologize
for that obviously for for all Scotch
fans watching as well but
um you know very crucial game for Wales
clearly to keep to keep them in
it is and maybe I'll have to support
them out of uh Celtic solidarity or
something like that I certainly haven't
quite recovered yet from the England
Iran game when England fans were
chanting at the Iranians Oru Scotland in
Disguise after they lost
6-2 wasn't it so
I think of the result of that I think I
might have to support the Welsh tomorrow
but but let's see though I mean
seriously I live in England my my
husband's English my children are half
English I think I will do my bit and
maybe won't be shouting the loudest but
but I will be willing them to uh I will
be willing them to do well uh The
Underdogs Wales managed to uh to beat
them however they wouldn't be too
disappointed either yeah we all love an
underdog isn't it it's the ilk of being
British anyway
um very quick question not quick
question a quick look at the paper in
the sun
um bogg Brothers watching Lou
um you might have to explain Harry well
look I explained how quite how long we
spent on that headline which was quite a
while this morning but no Steve Barkley
the house actually gave a speech today
uh where he was slightly chatting away
at the end of it in a q a and he's sort
of started to freelance a little bit on
all these ideas that have come across
his desk including microchipping new
rhinos so that you know people go to the
lou in them and new technology now so
Advanced that actually
um it could analyze your urine and tell
you who've got a disease or an illness
um way way way before you're showing
symptoms and you know he said down the
line with the right conversation uh with
the public you could get to a stage
where early diagnosis is done in a world
like that I think it's some years off I
think there are massive civil liberties
arguments to happen the interesting
point he made actually
I'm so sorry it's a half explanation
we'll see you later Harry and Pippa
thank you for very much indeed